der sommer 2020 wird der heißeste sommer
seit menschengedenken so die prognose
der weltwetterorganisation wmo
die rede ist von einem zitat
katastrophenszenario demnach könnten im
bevorstehenden sommer top werte nahe der
40 grad marke erreicht werden zudem
drohen waldbrände und ein großes
unwetter potenzial vor allem wegen der
korona pandemie ist es wichtig sich
darauf vorzubereiten klicks um seine
user gibt es regelmäßig spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktivität locker nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen
klicks um ist teil der
bildungsinitiative von freddys for
future wir bilden zukunft unter diesem
hashtag gibt es weitere spannende
inhalte
laut der weltwetterorganisation wmo
droht uns in diesem jahr ein hitzesommer
der alle rekorde brechen könnte und
schon die ersten monate des laufenden
jahres hatten darauf hingedeutet dass
2020 eines der heißesten jahre seit
beginn der messungen werden könnte laut
dem britischen wetterdienst met office
handelt es sich um eine zitat schock
prognose ganz europa werde unter einer
rekordhitze samt dürre echten auf die
aktuelle prognose für den sommer 2020
des us-wetterdienstes noah geht in diese
richtung ebenso wie die des europäischen
wetterdienstes ecm wf beide
langzeitprognosen vom wetter in
deutschland sagen einen sehr trockenen
sommer voraus das wetter modell des
privaten us wetterdienstes accuweather
ist noch eine stufe härter dazu der
meteorologe dominik jung accuweather
zeichnet für den sommer 2020 ein
europäisches katastrophenszenario diese
prognose macht wirklich angst die rede
ist von top werten nahe der 40 grad
marke außerdem drohen hitzewellen in
deutschland spanien frankreich und polen
doch nicht nur dass deutschland und
mitteleuropa müssen demnach auch mit
starken unwettern rechnen
schwül warmes bis heißes wetter in
kombination mit gewittern die ein großes
unwetter potenzial bergen das ist die
wenig verheißungsvolle prognose die
fachleute begründen das mit der lage
deutschlands gelegen in der mitte
zwischen großer trockener hitze und
wechselhaften kühlen luftmassen bei den
brit
den inseln aus europa müsse zudem mit
einer dürre rechnen und spanien mit
extremen waldbränden gemeinden und
städte müssten sich vor allem angesichts
der korona pandemie auf diesen möglichen
hitzesommer 2020 vorbereiten so die
weltwetterorganisation wmo dazu gibt es
konkrete pläne
aber der reihe nach der klimawandel ist
schon längst im gange seit beginn der
wetteraufzeichnung fanden die drei
heißesten sommer nach dem jahr 2000
statt der letzte sommer dagegen der zu
kalt war liegt bereits 30 jahre zurück
in erinnerung bleibt vor allem der
sommer 2013 ein extrem trockenes jahr
mit einer gewaltigen hitzewelle und
temperaturen bis zu rund 47 grad eine
der größten naturkatastrophen die der
kontinent je gesehen hat flüsse waren
ausgetrocknet wälder abgebrannt und
zehntausende menschen starben damals
es traf vor allem ältere leute denn
klimaanlagen versagten und die
krankenhäuser waren überfüllt mit hitze
opfern auch der sommer 2009 10 hatte es
in sich es gab gleich mehrere
hitzewellen hintereinander offiziell
handelt es sich beim jahr 2019 um das
zweitwärmste seit beginn der
wetteraufzeichnungen im jahr 1881 der
sommer war heiß und trocken und somit
problematisch für böden wälder und die
landwirtschaft ähnlich wie es auch schon
2018 der fall war dazu thomas
deutschländer vom deutschen wetterdienst
das war alles ein klein bisschen weniger
ausgeprägt als 2018 bis auf einen punkt
wir hatten im hochsommer mehrere
wirklich extreme hitze phasen wo wir
tatsächlich mit 42 6 grad in lingen
einen neuen deutschen hitze rekord
erreicht haben das war tatsächlich noch
extremer als im vorjahr insgesamt elf
der zwölf monate des jahres 2009 10
waren zu warm und das ist keine
momentaufnahme denn in deutschland
fanden neun der zehn wärmsten jahre in
den vergangenen 20 jahren statt seitdem
die wetteraufzeichnungen im jahr 1981
gestartet wurden müssen wir in
deutschland einen erwärmungstrend von
plus 1,6 grad celsius verzeichnen
regelmäßig mit dabei auch extreme
hitzewellen was laut klima experten und
expertinnen alles andere als normales
gemeint sind damit zeiten in denen es
mehrere tage lang hintereinander
deutlich wärmer ist als im durchschnitt
laut dem klimaforscher mojib latif aus
kiel hat sich die zahl der hitze werden
seit 1980 mindestens verdoppelt zum teil
sogar verdreifacht die zahl ist
inzwischen sehr hoch ganz klar eine
folge des klimawandels die wetter
katastrophe von 2009 10 spielte sich vor
allem von emden bis zum erzgebirge ab
vor allem im osten deutschlands hatte
der wassermangel und die daraus
entstehende dürre katastrophale folgen
einige regionen waren so trocken wie nie
seit dem beginn der aufzeichnungen vor
rund 50 jahren in sachsen anhalt und
thüringen war der boden damals bis zu
zwei meter tief ausgetrocknet hier in
berlin floss die spree rückwärts in
niedersachsen kamen die wasserwerke
nicht mehr hinterher um den wasserbedarf
aus eigener kraft zu stemmen ein viel
größeres problem ist solch eine dürre
für die wirtschaft der pegel der elbe in
dresden war beispielsweise auf 55
zentimeter gefallen und auch andere
flüsse in betroffenen gebieten führten
deutlich weniger wasser als sonst so war
der warenverkehr über die flüsse gar
nicht mehr oder nur eingeschränkt
möglich vor allem aber auch die
landwirte leiden unter der hitze und
trockenheit und dem daraus resultierende
wassermangel sie fürchten um ihre ernte
und existenz und steigen vermehrt auf
kulturen um die gut mit trockenheit klar
kommen zum beispiel hafer linsen und
hirse klar ist aber auch dass solch eine
extreme hitze wie fachleute sie nun auch
für den kommenden sommer prognostizieren
auch für den menschlichen körper
ausnahmezustand bedeutet sie kann fatale
folgen für unsere gesundheit haben und
sogar zur vorzeitigen todesfällen führen
natürlich hat der menschliche organismus
verschiedene mittel um gegen die hitze
anzugehen doch wenn die wärmeeinwirkung
zu groß wird bricht das kühlsystem
zusammen sensoren auf der menschlichen
haut und im inneren des körpers messen
die temperatur und werden in unserem
gehirn abgeglichen ist die
umgebungstemperatur stark erhöht droht
eine überhitzung dann muss der körper
maßnahmen einleiten um sich zu kühlen
zunächst werden die blutgefäße erweitert
um die abgabe von wärme an die umgebung
zu maximieren doch das hat folgen denn
dadurch werden die organe weniger
durchblutet beispielsweise die skelett
muskeln und so fühlen wir uns träge und
schlapp die verminderte durchblutung des
darms kann durchfall zur folge haben
reicht diese erhöhte haupt durchblutung
nicht aus beginnt der körper an zu
schwitzen dass es wirklich der
wirkungsvollste mechanismus um eine
überhitzung zu verhindern
denn durch die verdunstung des schweißes
gibt der körper wärme energie ab und
kühlt sich ab ein normal trainieren der
erwachsenen kann pro stunde etwa zwei
liter schweiß abgeben
manche sportler kommen sogar auf 4 liter
und den körper weiter auf touren zu
halten und ihm die nährstoffe wieder
zurückzuführen die durch das schwitzen
verloren werden müssen wir trinken und
essen andernfalls droht eine gefährliche
dehydrierung also der wassermangel und
muskelkrämpfe wenn die relative
luftfeuchtigkeit aber über 75 prozent
beträgt kann der schweiß auf der haut
nicht mehr verdunsten dann droht ein
hitzestau im körper menschen die der
prallen sonne ausgesetzt sind und keinen
kopfschutz tragen bringen auch ihr
hirngewebe und ihre hirnhaut in gefahr
stich vor sonnenstich das ist eine
thermische irritation des gehirns die
schwindel übelkeit und eine störung des
bewusstseins mit sich bringen kann
bei sehr großer hitze droht aber auch
ein hitzekollaps eine stressreaktion des
körpers denn die organe brauchen mehr
sauerstoff die folge das herz kreislauf
system muss richtig ranklotzen und es
kommt zur herzrasen ein hitzeschlag
entwickelt sich wenn das körpereigene
kühlsystem zusammen bricht der körper
ist dann akut überhitzt die
kerntemperatur steigt auf mehr als 40
grad an
dann kann das gehirn anschwellen und es
drohen bleibende schäden und im
schlimmsten fall auch der tod
doch nicht nur die menschen leiden unter
den heißen und trockenen sommern vor
allem die wälder könnten hart von einer
weiteren dürre getroffen werden denn
durstige und gestresste bäume sind
anfällig für klagen wie etwa den
borkenkäfer der sich bei wärme und
trockenheit besonders wohl fühlt die
trockenheit vergrößert außerdem die
gefahr für waldbrände und die pflanzen
leiden nicht nur unter dem wassermangel
auch der transport von nährstoffen aus
dem boden verringert sich die nährstoffe
aus dem dünger verbleiben also im boden
regnet es kommt es zu hören nitrat
gehalten im grundwasser also ein
endloses szenario was sich da alles an
eine große dürre anschließend der
fachwelt bezweifelt niemand dass die
probleme mit trockenheit und dürre in
der zukunft größer werden der
niederschlags zyklus im mittel europa
verschiebt sich schon seit jahren hin
immer mehr ins extreme im winter haben
die regenmengen demnach um rund zehn
prozent zugenommen deutlich trockener
dagegen präsentieren sich die
sommermonate regionale klimamodelle
bestätigen das
prognostizieren für deutschland eine
höhere wahrscheinlichkeit für längere
trockenphasen der klimawandel lässt
grüßen dazu sei niemals ein sprecher der
nichtregierungsorganisation european and
mental büro die häufigkeit und
intensität von dürren wird aufgrund des
klimawandels zu nehmen
auf dasselbe ergebnis kam auch ein
forschungsteam vom helmholtz zentrum für
umweltforschung fz vor zwei jahren dazu
heißt es die globale klimaerwärmung wird
das problem der dürren in europa
verschärfen dürren werden länger dauern
mehr flächen und damit mehr menschen
betreffen erwärmt sich die erde um drei
grad celsius werden extremereignisse wie
die dürre im märz 2003 künftig in weiten
teilen europas der normalzustand sein
erst anfang des jahres 2020 hatte der
deutsche wetterdienst mit einer klima
vorhersage die bisherige lücke für die
kommenden zehn jahre geschlossen eine
echte premiere
die beteiligten klima
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
nutzten für ihre vorhersage unzählige
weitere vorhersagen die sie aber mit
leicht veränderten bedingungen durch
rechneten und somit genauer ins visier
nahmen denn klar ist dass das
klimasystem auch natürlichen
schwankungen unterworfen ist dadurch
entstehen unsicherheiten die das
erstellen einer seriösen und
langfristigen vorhersage schwierig
machen doch die statistische abschätzung
jeweils mit leicht veränderten
bedingungen hat eine gewisse lösungs
vielfalt zum ergebnis laut der neuen
klima vorhersage könnte es in den
kommenden zehn jahren um 1,5 grad
celsius wärmer werden als es in den
vergangenen drei jahrzehnten
durchschnittlich der fall war für den
norden und süden des landes wird genau
dieser temperaturanstieg von 1,5 grad
celsius prognostiziert in der mitte
deutschlands könnte es sogar um zwei
grad wärmer werden
in der klima vorhersage für die nächsten
zehn jahre kommen auch die erwarteten
niederschlagsmengen vor die kommenden
vier jahre bis 2024 werden demnach wohl
zu trocken werden diese trockenphasen
könnten möglicherweise unterbrochen
werden von tage mit extremen
niederschlägen dazu stephan natz von den
berliner wasserbetrieben wir sehen das
genauso wie der deutsche wetterdienst
eine zunahme von starkregen ereignissen
lässt sich aus den daten unseres dichten
messnetzes noch nicht ablesen aber
langfristig werden wir stabile
wetterlage
mit langen schönwetterperiode sehen und
dann regnet es junge hunde und zwar
heftig diese vorhersagen sind vor allem
für die land- und forstwirtschaft enorm
wichtig denn für die bewässerung ihrer
felder nutzen die bauern grundwasser
doch wenn die wasserspeicher im boden
nicht durch regen aufgefüllt werden
gehen auch diese reserven irgendwann zur
neige
denn sturzregen können die
grundwasserreserven nicht auffüllen zu
viel wasser fließt einfach ab höchste
zeit also endlich was in sachen
klimaschutz zu tun
dazu der präsident der weltorganisation
für meteorologie wmo gerhard adrian wir
sind die erste generation die die
auswirkungen des menschengemachten
klimawandels so umfassen messen
beobachten und wissenschaftlich
analysieren kann
dieses wissen ist in der welt und lässt
sich nicht mehr unter den tisch kehren
doch auch kurzfristig gesehen müssen die
städte und gemeinden sich jetzt dringend
auf einen möglichen hitzesommer 2020 auf
der nordhalbkugel vorbereiten so der
appell der weltwetterorganisation wmo
die menschen müssen vor der hitze
geschützt werden in früheren jahren ist
der bevölkerung angeraten worden
gekühlte einkaufszentren aufzusuchen und
gefährdete nachbarn bekannte regelmäßig
zu besuchen
die korona pandemie schutzmaßnahmen
gestalten dass jetzt aber schwieriger
zudem haben sich viele krankenhäuser auf
corona patientinnen und patienten
eingestellt und weniger auf patientinnen
und patienten mit hitzschlag
auf der anderen seite könnte und solch
ein sommer im kampf gegen das corona
virus auch mehr zeit verschaffen dazu
der virologe alexander kekulé in der ard
wenn es warm wird werden die korona
wären normalerweise schwächer und die
krankheit schwächt sich ab der sommer
könnte unser bester verbündeter sein
das wetter wird extremer wir sind
mittendrin im klimawandel anklicken
anschauen klicks um science and future
abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran